we flew him all the way from Phoenix
Arizona and Las Vegas Nevada on this
week's food truck Diaries it's Harrison
Rogers the owner of the UFL Fight League
and the UFC legend himself Frank Mayer
and I'm feeding them chicken cutlets New
Jersey style let's go
[Music]
let's go fellas what is up the legend
Frank Mir as usual Harrison the
Magnificent wonder the president of the
UFL boys look at us little La son for
you bad politics good weather that's why
I say about L.A
but fellas you guys uh you got a lot
going on man you get some too busy dudes
busy in the business and Frank you know
this and Harrison I'm sure Frank's give
me some tips on this but whenever you
decide to start a league you know
Frank's been doing longer than I have
but I've been around a little bit it
it's a tough task man we've seen a lot
of leagues come and go the thing with
the UFL though is you guys are doing a
little different a little different than
these other leagues and really giving
back to the fighters which is what
caught my curiosity and why I support
you guys so much because you're actually
giving back to the fighters if you want
to talk about that with like you know
we'll get into Frank and Bella fighting
which is I'm so excited about we'll talk
about it we'll talk about that monster
we'll talk about her in the nil deal
she's richer than both of us already but
uh with uh starting a league in the way
you're giving back to the fighters
you're talking about health insurance
which most people would say there's a
reason why these other major leagues in
uh mixed martial arts doesn't do health
insurance because it's kind of a
nightmare right oh yeah no that's what
we're doing right now but it's so fun to
talk about Healthcare in a past tense
we've done it like so many people you
know in this industry talk about oh
we're gonna do this and we're gonna do
this and it'll be really cool if we did
this we've done it we had our first
event where all of our Fighters have
health insurance that now they're going
into their second Camp you know they we
have sound bite after sound bite of them
being like I feel so much more confident
to go hard in the in the training camp
because they're covered there and then
also what's really different is it's a
fighter-owned league you know these
Fighters they got their shares after
their ceremonial weigh-in like hey you
fought in this first event you're gonna
be taken care of forever with it
obviously shares for one event is lower
than if you're with us for years and
years years sure but it'll take care of
you as much as you put into it and so
for them to have shares each time they
fight they act differently you know when
you own something you treat it
differently and so we had Fighters with
the F3 drink you know after their they
win and they're all sponsoring you we
don't have to tell them to do that
because they know that they own it yeah
it's good what's good for you is good
for them that's one thing that actually
hasn't done a phenomenal job when we
first met realizing that like look you
know give me a jack of all trades and
Masters now it's really the expression
and you know he's a great businessman
but when he started asking about the
fight thing I was like all right well
let's start putting some key people in
certain roles and you know I mean first
we did the first round manager helps us
with a shirt for a show which worked out
as a blessing we were able to have
Sophia magana come over as our CEO and
she's been
you know he's amazing you know and
everything from there like we put Brian
Lacy I was like hey you need the
commentator you know Quentin Jackson too
brought them in you know Gail uh Galen
uh brought him in to help out now to his
chief marketing operator operations and
so like
that was one of the things the first
impression about Harrison was I was like
hey look we got to put these different
people to help us out and then he did
and then started asking okay what are
the problems with the organization
what's going on you know we have people
like Tim Sylvia who can't even have his
arm fixture I mean you know I'm like you
have guys that fought for years to
really helped build a brand on their
shoulders Legends and they're not
benefited all from here they can't even
go to Walmart still without you know
taking pictures and can't help their
wife you know but then there's no
financial compensation so right off the
bat he figured out a way because those
are the things again like I didn't know
how to get health insurance started for
a company or do anything like that he
goes well well that's the problem he
went and got it broken he took care of
it because well that part I can handle
so that's one thing I think that we're
really doing well at the uh you know
Freedom uh the United flight league is
that everybody kind of has like all
right well I can handle that it's my
field of expertise you know from you
know Quentin all the way down uh and
taking their role and knowing how to
make sure that this is going to be a
company that we fix all those issues
that that again like you know what are
you talking about like it's a sound bite
with Jake Paul talking about oh we're
going to start a fight leaders or a uh
you know a union I've heard that it
stops there man that's it that's all it
happens hey whatever happened with that
and it hits a huge you know sound bite
but no one ever follows through like we
actually now it's no longer a sound bite
like our Fighters have health insurance
yeah like it's not we're going to so we
have we did yeah yeah so I yeah I think
that's a way to make a splash that's for
sure in this sport because you know
Frank's been doing it long and I have
but we've both been around the block
where you know this isn't something I
even thought of where Fighters get
health insurance or anything like that
and you're so confident in UFL I mean
your own daughters yeah I don't know any
more stamp of approval I can tell people
like hey man yeah look we all get we're
all brand ambassadors right yeah I make
money they I've drank this I take this
you know and there's some guys out there
that really it's like you really hey man
like you know cameras aren't watching do
you really like this product you know
and I've talked to guys it's like nah
man I just they put money in my account
yeah so for people to go well you know
UFL pays you you're your owner in the
company uh of course you're pushing it
amount yeah but I'm actually gonna put
my daughter on The Fight Card well she's
actually one of our Fighters I don't
know of any way to really tell anybody
how much I approve of a company I'll be
like hey you know what I don't know how
many fights I have left in me maybe only
one more maybe you know who sees how
that one goes you know but uh there's
only one time that I can fight for with
my daughter on a car yeah well that
works out I'm like oh well I know where
I want to have it done at where it's
going to be the best opportunity for her
to be taken care of in the best way and
that's here under the brand and
especially with Bella it's not like an
options thing because you look at her
skill level well she she could have went
anywhere in the world is such a
nightmare I mean let's get this straight
just so the audience knows Bella signed
an nil deal with the UFC correct UFC
already I mean that's one thing we're
doing that you know like we actually
it's you know when and contingency a
little bit with Harrison I'm going to
show him how to deal with stress yes
when our relationship said and done I'm
going to turn him around because
we all have a strong suits and stress is
mine and he knows that necessarily his
what he's going through most Fighters at
Frank's level we handle stress pretty
well it's crazy yeah so we you know
Bella's going to do another fight on the
fight pass before she moves on you know
and fights on our card so she wants to
get two fights in this summer and so
that being said there's a lot of moving
Parts going on but yeah Bella look we
sat down and had lunch with Dana Dana's
I don't know if there's a bigger fan
between Harrison or Dana on Bella you
know he knows what she is and basically
said it very you know poetically you
know in fact it was actually an argument
between me and Jen on whether Bella goes
to college or not you know Jen was like
why go and go wrestle in college and
blow your knee out rip your shoulder and
you're doing it for free or for a
scholarship right she's old go make
money now you know I mean like right off
the bat and then paste your college if
you want to yeah where were you at on it
I was kindly at first I was completely
again I want to do what Bella wants to
do Bella's like I want to really push
the rest in as far as I can see if we
can go to the Olympics or world channel
I don't love that for her I'm like
that's awesome though and that's to me
it's not a step backwards we know the
sport of MMA a wrestling pedigree like
that we know where that's only going to
help her out especially in her division
correct absolutely dominating you know
you see the wrestling it's phenomenal
right and then you add striking and
submissions on that you have the most
dangerous fighter in the world right uh
so I was like well whatever makes her
happy but then Jennifer about the point
she was okay talk about cage cage won a
second see title now as a sophomore in
high school he's a state champion
football team on the top four in the
country she was cages playing football
right and he gets the opportunity to go
pro do you have him stay in college you
go probably well no he would turn pro
she says wait a minute so you're gonna
say that for football I'm like different
it's different okay so you're building
so I was like well
football's so dangerous everybody I mean
a practice you tear your name and
there's so much competition and whatnot
I'm like with the wrestling I'm like I
get it because she get injured
absolutely I don't think the injuries
are anywhere near themselves and for
what it's going to give her without a
college experience the experience of
wrestling on a World level at that level
it's only gonna add so it's like so she
can go fight five fights right now and
go make anywhere between ten to fifty
thousand dollars and work her way up and
then maybe your eighth ninth fight from
now you know she's in you know six digit
numbers
um or she can go in and let me go metal
in her first fight as soon as that's
over you know what I mean like maybe
seven figures also I I would say for
your life and you know don't shoot the
messenger but I would say fighting is a
marathon not a Sprint football's a
Sprint well if as soon as you get to
that
NBA too it's a Sprint yeah 100 so but it
was a good thing I just sat in the
office with Dana and Dana was like you
know what hey she has a rest of her life
to fight she's so young and this time
she was 18. and she's like look she has
the rest no she could you know he even
made a joke
Point them he goes he's still fighting
you're gonna be like yeah come on yeah
you fight you can't go and wrestle I'm
like no
if I you know so hard to go backwards so
he was actually the Tipping Point and
then you know taking care of the fact
that you know well you know he actually
alleviated the issue with Bella in the
college for tuition he's like well now
we got to pay for her tuition because
obviously the scholarships aren't full
rides for wrestling and they have I
think the college team has about six
scholarships and they divide them up you
know so Bella got a good a decent one
for for what wrestling is it's not a
fool you're like we got you UFC got you
yeah that's them right off the bat
they're like hey we got it and she can
go fight wherever like right you know he
didn't give me any speculation or so you
know of like well we want her we don't
want her to go here so hey look go get
experience go win titles
come here when you're ready well and
that was his point too that I brought up
I don't want to be overconfident I
always bring up lomachenko as an example
lomachenko the greatest one of the
greatest boxers of all time the guy was
over 396 or 97 and one is an amateur yes
multiple gold medals in the Olympics
world champion he lost once to uh the
Russian gold medalists and came back and
beat him twice his first fight and he's
like I'm gonna be Pro and fight for
title on my first fight goes and fights
to the guy's home salido and fights him
in Texas lost loss no I've heard that
maybe I never saw the fight but they're
like oh well you know he was allowed to
the guy they didn't let him get away I'm
like but but the problem is you guys
were so confident with his ability that
he's a world beater and he was that like
that overconfidence cost you that zero
especially in fighting but also back to
that point his dad when he was uh young
and he was like ready to go on the
amateur circuit his dad made him do
ballet for fighting four years
you need to work on your footwork and do
ballets slow your roll to Marathon not a
Sprint fighting's a marathon and so
that's why I don't want to be lomachenko
situation where Bella we think oh well
she could walk through everybody and
once you go to UFC also we find out
maybe fight in front of you know 15 to
20 000 people is a stressful situation
who knows we don't know I don't know yet
I don't want to find out I don't want to
find out that's in Square Garden and
then what do you go from there we're
already in the UFC we're 20 years old do
we go did we leave and come back yeah
it's not the end of the world you could
but that's a tough way to do it it's not
the way to do it let's take a little
break from chat with the boys at UFL
because this episode of food truck dies
brought to you by the one the only the
tried and true on it that's right listen
your boy here does a million jobs I do
way too many podcasts then I'm on tour
then I'm a dad I'm non-stop I need all
the mental help I can get that's why I
depend on Alpha Brain the best nootropic
on planet Earth they've sold over a
million bottles Nationwide on it so
confident in uh Alpha Brain that they
will give you your money back no re no
return necessary go ahead and keep it
share it with a friend that's how
confident they are in their Alpha Brain
the best nootropic ever but you've heard
of Alpha Brain everyone their mom knows
Alpha Brain what about Alpha Brain Black
what you know about that black Alpha
Brain that's right it's a highly
concentrated Alpha Brain that I use four
little pills your boys creating all
sorts of apps I'm doing computer
programming I don't I don't know where
it comes from it's off of brain black
that's how good it is AIDS and mental
processing it's caffeine free all right
helps with the flow State promotes Focus
supports memory you think more clearly
under stress you react a little more
quick like a cat all right you want to
be more like a cat get some Alpha Brain
Black right on it also offers
crazy workout equipment if you've never
heard of it you're living under a rock
you're talking about telebells steel
Club Macy's sandbags yoga mats they got
streaming Fitness for your thick self
and if you need nutrition to get that
summer body it's a thick Boy Summer it's
always thick Boy Summer but not too
thick right you got to get your stuff
together so that's why they have all the
best nutrition we're talking about
creatine they got freaking all sorts of
delicious stuff like protein powders
Warrior bars they got it all whatever
you're looking for they got
multivitamins they got total gut health
everything you need to get your thick
self in shape on it has it for you but
if you want to try the best nootropic on
the planet you got to go to onnit.com
you save 10 off all the workout gear
uh clothing uh kettlebells streaming
Fitness and Alpha Brain Alpha Brain
instant Alpha Brain shot the Alpha Brain
regular the Alpha Brain Black that I
told you about all right that's anna.com
shop 10 off now let's get back to the
program but I I'll never Ed Soros told
me this because I remember when I was
fighting I was training at black house
and uh they asked me some and I was like
man I just got the call from my manager
and Ed knows the game forever and I was
like man I don't like this match-up boy
he goes what are you talking about I
don't like the matchup man I feel like
this guy there's better matchups he goes
huh you're in the UFC I know he goes I
tell my guys all the same thing when you
get to the UFC unless you can find a way
to beat anybody they offer you you're
not ready for the UFC he's like you take
that fight man you there's so I can look
at that guy and find ways for you to
beat him he's like but I tell my guys do
not fight in UFC unless you're ready to
face all of them he's like it's not a
theater lead they're not going to give
any buildups they're doing a little
better now like they've learned the
lesson with like Darren till or certain
guys you see what they've done with
sugar O'Malley and Patty pamlett where
it might be a little you know they're
building sugar up they're building Patty
up it used to be you know how I mean
your first fight lead your first fight
can fight insane you still look at my
Wikipedia it's murderous row mine too I
mean dude I came off thousand five and
six months later I'm fighting Gabriel
Gonzaga I'm like what the [__] am I
doing you know so it's like you gotta be
ready to go so for Bella I think it's
dope that Dana he knows this like yeah
go fight in UFL or maybe she's the king
of UFL and then can come over eventually
titles yeah and in that situation I can
pick opponents I can sit there and go
well you know what I'd prefer this girl
over that girl this we have more to gain
here we have nothing to gain well let's
find a South Pole
hey you know what this time let's find
out how you do against a high level
let's go ahead and try this out we're
gonna do this girl but you're only gonna
say it's a guy who we fighting there
really is no negotiations hey who we
fight you know because if you say no or
you pull back you're you're done look I
said no one time in my whole career and
that was because the opponent I was
gonna face we had the same circle of
friends like basically his head trainer
was one of my groomsmen in my wedding
Jesus so I was like dude he and I are
going to understand this yeah we punch
each other in the gym all the time like
but everybody around us is going to be
weird when this is said and done so at
first I said no oh really no the only
time in my life I ever tried to get out
of before I was like ah okay do a
re-pick you know somebody else they're
like well you know we don't know when we
get you back in the car but basically
you're gonna sit we're gonna shelf you
for over here to punish you yeah oh same
thing I mean without saying it you know
oh well we might not get back to you
it's pretty tied up yeah man if you
don't take this opportunity I was like
oh damn so it was like all right well
hey never mind I'll take the fight you
know what I mean like I'm in yeah
Roy yeah I was Roy yeah yeah that's
right yeah that's right yeah same thing
with me with matrion I remember because
me and Mitchell came I thought didn't
fight it and they called me to fight him
in Toronto I'm like you'll see 165 I'm
like what I'm gonna fight Matt that's my
buddy like well he told us he's ready to
tear your head off I'm like Matt said
that like I'm like uh you can't have
anybody else until I talked to Roy I
called right now they told me you wanted
to find them yeah I called now I'm like
hey you want to tear my head off he's
like no I told him no I'm like I told
them no
so they got the same script yeah yeah
they've been through this before but I
think uh great too and Harrison you
learned this is I'm sure you already
learned it you don't have to compete
with UFC there's enough eyeballs there's
enough tickets to be sold there's enough
fights there's a big enough fan base
where it's you don't have to UFC's not
your competition we were literally you
guys have to do that no UFL yeah we were
saying like Bella we know that a lot of
our studs are gonna go to UFC and we
love that because that you know we're a
new commodity we're building a community
that we think is the long game that
you know when Fighters own something
after 10 years and you have all this
stock we're going to have the talent and
we're gonna have the pool of people who
the Accolade of being a UFL champ
hopefully it'll be just as
proud to say as a UFC it's not going to
happen overnight and we know that we're
not trying to compete with that but
we're building we think the future have
been made that it's more of like an MBA
model where the players are taking care
of the athletes are they see more of a
life after we want to be with this and
and so yeah we're not we don't look at
it as a competition we there's enough
meat on the bone for us all to eat right
now but we think we're I'm sure just
having those kind of goals and offering
even those benefits it's not going to be
hard to recruit these young prospects oh
no already as far as not being the UFC
our pay is and the way we take care of
Fighters are really there is no
intelligence second choice yeah it's
like if you can get the UFL before you
go to the 100 and really my goal as part
of my you know my contribution to the
company is I want to make it to win
Bella right now it wants to be a UFC
champion I'm not stopping that from her
but I would like it by the time three or
four years come around I would like to
make that kind of like tougher decision
yeah you know maybe I'll go and get the
ulfl champ first and maybe I want to
keep them maybe I don't don't want to go
to the UFC yeah and maybe she still does
but I don't want it to be that you're
not doing me a favor but I want to make
it to the company and the organization
has enough you know a recognition and
just you know pedigree that it's like oh
okay well actually you know what being
the pride Champion you'll see Champion I
mean like there was a time where you
know I was going to say I'll do you one
better because I think you're the only
guy who can pull this off both of you
guys are especially your relationship
with Dana White how dope would it be if
Bella's the first UFL champ and UFC
champs simultaneously because they're
super super fights make all the sense
I'd love for you see it happening so
much I would love for a Bellator to have
some of the guys fight UFC let's find
out who's the baddest they have some
great Champion we haven't done that
during 2001 2002. with pride was oh
their Peak you know what I mean you know
Fedora you know what I mean Crow company
at that point Quentin was over there
there was a lot of debate who's better
Randy you know because Randy was you
know stuck there you know in Tito that's
when they're into uh Randy versus uh uh
Fedor yeah that was like this close to
happening yeah you know and then we got
closer doing it a little bit when when
Chuck went over and competed in the
tournament yeah I mean but it was like
well how great would that event have a
night of fights we're like all right
cool you guys heavyweight champion it's
our Super Bowl heavyweights once a year
light heavy weight all the way down
let's just do a team UFC team Pride if
we could have done something like that
could you imagine the spectators oh
agree yeah it'd be legendary Bellator
did it with ryzen it was ridiculous yeah
amazing man I mean the outcome was a
little one-sided but yeah it just shows
you Bel tour don't mess around yeah
that's why I have some legit legit
Fighters man across the board right now
you know with kind of the chaos that's
going on with people you know France
naganu or whoever that are now or Nick
Diaz UFL is like trying to make a move
you know I don't know if we're allowed
to say this because I don't know if he's
in a contract and technically as a
promoter but as a podcaster and stuff I
want to talk to these people and say
you've talked about Healthcare before
you've talked about having your own
sponsorship referring to Nate Francis
yeah you can talk about them they're
free agents yeah okay and Nick you can't
Nate and Francis you can't but how cool
would a Francis naganu Ryan Bader like I
know that's totally different agent but
and he's and Vader is with uh but he's
not gonna be with Bellator forever but
he's a current champ yeah and he's you
know Francis is a free agent yeah but
friends free agent yeah so I don't know
I dig it man I look great I like where
you guys are headed because we just need
to make some moves but I agree all these
moves are making me hungry let me fill
you what is it some chicken cutlets now
you're just a food truck this is a Food
Van Food Van that's food though right
yeah that's food and hopefully not kids
in the back whenever I see a van I
always get creeped out but let's uh
let's feed you guys and continue this
talk man
[Music]
foreign
's pretty lit too though
yeah this chicken Palms had to go wrong
with man and this is how they do it in
Jersey case a little little East Coast
Vibe here
let's take another short little break
here from chat with the boys at UFL and
UFC Legend heavyweight title Contender
heavyweight champion Frank Mayer the one
and only and our boy Harrison who's the
Mastermind behind UFL because this
episode of food truck Dyer is brought to
you by happy happy hippo happyhippo.com
the best Kratom on planet Earth so I can
give you that crazy Buzz feeling like if
you take like a crazy energy drink or
something with a lot of caffeine like a
cup of coffee nope it's gonna get you in
that mood to get stuff done whatever you
got for your busy day that Kratom is
going to help you but you can't just
trust any Kratom that's why I reached
out to happy hippo and said hey how
about you guys jump on board all the
program I'm doing because I use your
product every day now I use the shot
they have the sour apple shot the
butterscot shot they have gummies they
have powders they have tablets they got
it all whatever form you want your
perfect kratom in they got you covered
man and here's the cool thing about it
I'm giving you 20 off when you go to
happyhippo.com promo code thick23 that's
t-h-i-c-c-c three species 23 all right
if you use that promo code thick 23 you
get 20 stop for Life share it with a
friend share it with your mom your
cousins whoever you get to try the best
grade on the planet all right that's
Happy hippo.com promo code dick23 now
let's get back to the program back to
UFL not the sandwiches
I don't know if this is announcers but
is it August 12th is August 12th I think
we need a lot a lot of Mayor a lot of
Mayor little Bella Frank tandem is that
the plan
it's coming full circle because I don't
I don't know if you remember the first
episode you were on for our podcast
it was like brought up as like a oh
that'd be cool like oh can you imagine
bellamere fighting with Frank like
that'd be epic it's freaking happening
it's happening it's happening in Phoenix
in Phoenix August 12th
we're trying to figure out the logistics
because obviously Frank is the
commentator and voice of UFL a lot going
on for Frank that night and here's the
other thing Mike and gloves yeah dude
here's our thing he's calling you a
bonfire is Bella gonna be the main event
and then because then you can't be
co-main event you know honestly you know
what I'm gonna kind of like
obviously like there's a lot goes behind
that wall to sit and talk but as her
father I want to talk to her but what do
you feel most comfortable about yeah you
know I mean like she obviously has a lot
of Main Events ahead of her
do you want to fight earlier in the
night get yours out of the way mentally
you know what I mean and then focus on
Dad and focus on me and then I'll fight
you know I can go corner you while I'm
still waiting to fight yeah yeah you
know or you know like I would probably
prefer to do that and I think we can it
was an easy sell saying hey it's my last
fight
going on the main event yeah that'd be
cool whereas you know we're Bella
rightfully so she's going to be the
future could we make it to where she's
the main event
yeah but I just don't know with her
because she's going to Corner me you're
being more sense she kicks off the the
that's right the main card even if we
lose you even if
we're Technically she's a co-main event
swing bout yeah and then I fly here to
me yes time tween you know but I still
think her fighting first would be easier
and then I've actually even though UFO
we don't do amateur fights on there
we're sitting there in caves you know
because my son now has won the Second
City titled he's training with us and
doing boxing now
on top of all those wrestling practices
and you know he loves so I was like hey
do you want to do a amateur fight like
have him in the swing yeah well I'm
cornering you and Bella like Well yeah
if it's an amateur fight you want to go
out there and give it a shot like get in
your sleep
uh you know we'll just make it a night
of mirrors that'd be nuts oh yeah
what are you thinking she's like well
I'm the main event like no I know but we
wanna she's like no I don't care what
I'm the main event yeah yeah I doubt
you'd do that but yeah she it should I
in all reality it should kick off with
her and then you're the main event
I think for many reasons because yeah
being such a face of UFL the comics with
the poster you know but I also have
never seen
a father-daughter Duo so I'd respect
whatever you wanted to do yeah at least
we're kind of you know
crazy yeah they're not a lot because
LeBron talks about he goes he goes I'm
gonna retire once I play a game with
brownie his son crazy my son's getting
close there you know LeBron's up there
in eight so you kind of the first you
know the LeBron of although it's a
daughter so it's even more different
yeah it's nuts yeah it's all exciting
man you guys got to feel good about it
oh it's fun well you know hey Bella's
doing something she loves I'm glad that
I can provide it for a platform that you
know it's like you go to work every day
right and you said oh my kids are gonna
follow up in my career and I can sit
there oh I'm actually gonna make a
better work environment than I had
she's going to get a bigger share of the
money be taken care of as far as you
know I know they're you know health-wise
so she gets injured leading up to the
fight she's taken care of not the things
that we've had to deal with it's like
hey man how are you feeling like I'd
like to go to the doctor maybe get a
cortisone shot but if I mention it I
might get the fight pool for me and then
I got to pay for it I'm covered in my
own money I'm sure you've had some
nightmare experiences right like I had a
fight where I was fighting in uh this is
my third Pro fighting I was fighting in
uh Virginia Norfolk Virginia where it
was by George Mason University and I fly
out there I knocked the dude out and as
I knocked him out hit my thumb exploded
compound fracture exploded out and they
I think they paid me like four grand
maybe three grand two and two for that
fight and then I was like hey man I need
to go to the doctor my hands bleeding
everywhere but my dad and brother came
to the show like no let's go see the
exhibits in Washington DC like the
Lincoln Memorial and stuff so I'm
walking around like light head I'm like
Dad I need to go to the doctor we go to
the doctor and I they just didn't cover
it so I had to pay for I'd have health
insurance at the time
they're like don't worry we'll take care
of it so I go to the doctor assume it's
covered they just never covered it I
recovered it yeah so I I remember that
fight ended up costing me like six grand
you know because yeah pay money to fight
there's so many stories like so we do
have stories like that where it's just a
night Harrison sat down and talked about
the different things like hey like you
know if we're gonna get into this how do
we make it better you know because
Harrison you know had a couple fights
and amateurs so like you know a huge fan
of the sport but
making it a better than just you know
Harrison made his money without the
fighting never made it you know what I
mean this wasn't his idea to get rich to
go I'm already rich I'm trying to make
sure I don't become poor doing this you
know what I mean like please so you know
legitimately how do we make it you know
a better event and that's when things
attacked was like Hey The Taking Care
like you know life liberty The Pursuit
of Happiness right this is things are
supposed to have as an American and here
you know I mean like you know life is
your health you know there's so many
fighters we've all done it where
were injured in the camps but we can't
go get it fixed or addressed because it
financially falls on you so now it's
something where I'm like I told I said
hey look we're gonna have better fights
and probably cost less financially
because the fact that now a guy goes and
he might have a tear or something that
could be rehabbed or or something that
can be addressed why it's small it's
like hey let's go and get you while you
have a cold yeah well right now
everybody waits until they have the
full-blown flu and they're on a [__]
you know a breathing machine okay now
you're going to address it it's like
well man this is gonna cost a lot of
money it's like you know hey let's fix
your diet oh let's wait till you have to
have a quadruple bike yeah yeah well
there's different levels and because of
the way that we structure the health
care that they have at the minute they
they sign with us
and they have the ballot agreement
they're ready to fight all right cool
you can train now knowing that if you
get hurt we'll take care of you they
might not necessarily mean you get
pulled out of the fight yeah you can now
address the injury early enough that
maybe we could fix it yeah so now we get
a better Fighter for both sides I want
the fighters how do I guys go on their
injured I know that's dangerous as a fan
even if you're just a pure evil family I
just want to see the best guy fight the
best guy well then you want this to
happen too because you want to see the
healthiest person on yourself you want
to see some you know guys uh you know
shell of himself because he's got a
torch you know how depressing was that
to watch the fight with and I don't know
the circumstances
militia you know my shoulder popped out
30 times like man if there was a way we
could have maybe fixed it before and I
don't know if it could have but there's
an example of watching I mean Floyd
Mayweather Manny Pacquiao he had one arm
yeah why not yeah it's like insane 100
for my pay for you and you guys
compromise yeah oh my God that's
annoying I mean like so it's like as a
fight fan you sit there and go well [__]
like I didn't even see a fight I just
saw a guy who's half injured tried to
salvage himself because he had to and
money yeah okay he's a warrior he's
gonna go forward and it's like and I
know some guy said well he shouldn't be
doing it and I said how that works the
mindset that makes that guy do that is
not going to keep I think I pulled out
yeah but here's them there has to be a
reason why other leagues didn't decide
to go this route like I'm sure it's been
a nightmare trying to pull some of this
off oh yeah there has to be a reason why
these other major organizations don't
offer health care and I wonder if
now that I don't know the whole
relationship or the structure of WWE
partnership or ownership Now by UF
Endeavor bottom mode
I'm thinking they might now be required
and maybe they're about to announce it
the reason why
the reason why I'm able to do it is also
the reason why I'm required to do it is
I own other businesses and have over 500
employees that has a large employer I
have to offer Insurance to any employee
that I hire but that doesn't umbrella
out to you all your other yeah common
ownership really yeah because with the
UFC and WWE just so everyone's aware
those WWE athletes are independent
contractors right well that's how
they've gotten away with it this whole
time that if you have all independent
contractors and you technically have
below a certain amount of W-2 employees
yes you don't have to offer certain
benefits but
it's kind of a it's kind of a weird
two-edged sword for this industry is
because a lot of employers are like I
want to stay under a certain amount of
employees so they don't have to yeah
since I've already done it and so
insurance carriers you know if you were
just this type of business an insurance
carrier would be like I don't want to
touch that because they're such high
risk you know people
but
I already have the group plan with my
parent business
now that I have this new entity that
same Insurance can't disqualify this
business because I'm required to offer
it but I'm sure you're your your rate
goes through the roof right it does but
the to have access to that ability that
nobody else would have uh insured
obviously the league will pay for that
portion the skyrocketed the whole group
but
it has capability which other companies
even if they paid triple the amount that
I'm paying yeah that I'm paying they
wouldn't they just wouldn't have the
option yeah that's so interesting and so
it's really kind of a cool thing that I
think now other promotions don't have
the excuse that oh we just can't do it
the insurance carriers don't it goes
back to what I said about you to begin
with Harrison didn't do this to become
rich correct yeah I think you know I
mean let's face it there's a lot of
promoters that are like hey you get to
park a phantom in your garage but your
guy might not be you can have guys that
you know can't pay for their health care
you know they're going to be having to
you know work at a gym the rest of their
life to pay their dues you made money
out but are you cool with that yeah yeah
they are they're more than okay
they should have done better yeah I mean
like they should have figured how to do
it on their own it's on this it's on
them
yeah I mean like you know seos are like
that yeah that's what puts them in those
positions but most guys agree they're
sharks don't have you know Harrison's
mentality and be like hey I'm okay with
making a little bit less of the people
around me little bit more I mean you see
a few businessmen out there that are
that way you know what I mean otherwise
they've got great price and stuff and
that's kind of mentality to me yeah but
like first I mean both kinds of Amazon
like hey my guys you know I'm the
richest guy and I'm the richest men in
the world but my guys have to [__] a
piss in a water bottle yeah those
outliers yeah those outlines that's the
mindset that makes you feel really hard
I just I'm glad that you know Harrison
is that's one thing he brings to the
table he's not trying to become rich off
of him because of my money I'm obviously
he's made himself yeah but at the same
time I don't want to be in the business
of losing money but but at the same time
I don't think that was either that's not
it can't be your number one priority I
think and have a a company that's going
to be something to be proud of and be
like what was the what was the most
important thing the fiscal bottom number
the bottom line is like okay well that's
the most important thing that then
Fighters you know health and and their
abilities yeah it's going to take a hit
like so or would you want to make sure
the fighters could be happy about things
you know and have a very enriched
experience and be happy about a company
they're a part of then might you might
not make
yeah and I love it because you look at
you know make it a splash in the fight
game it's tough to do these days there's
a lot of leagues but your Splash
obviously Frank involved and Bella is a
big splash but the biggest splash is
offering this which is separates you
guys it really is Oh by far me and Bella
nobody's done it I'm happy about because
it brings us a lot of attention you know
I get to fulfill a dream that me and
Bella talked about now I'm like hey this
might actually really happen we might
both be getting our hands wrapped and
get to look at each other crazy Bella's
hands are gonna be wrapped you know
still for when she goes into my corner
and vice versa I'll already probably be
wrapped up while I'm cornering my
daughter knowing that I'm fighting to
him but if that can also bring attention
to the UFL
and see all the things that that we're
doing there it's like hey guys this is
great
this is only going to be you know this
is a one-time website but what can we
now when I'm shining the light on this
oh yeah what am I shining the light at
so we're just another promotion just out
there to try to like you know make it
you can't yeah there's another fight
okay man hits one and done this is over
with you I mean it's a cool poster on
the wall and Henry don't talk about for
me Bella but at the same time like I I
don't want that that's only half the
story for me personally is there have
you guys announced you talked about
opponents for Frank we we have a couple
that uh you know gets he actually has a
couple so he's like real best friends
with Chris Angel and Chris Angel has
some you want to fight Chris no no no
but training
he has really great ideas and so he's
throwing out some some names that where
his Angel has yeah I won't say him but
we're we're all over the map we're like
he's got his beginning too remember you
know all the times you have to have him
on the show and talk to him he's
interesting I would love to have a
Christmas I'll let him know yeah yeah
but um
yeah that'd be fun oh he is such with
Carolyn too
I think his girl is gonna like you know
like like flattened my tires so I can't
show up yeah because I train them
probably about four or five times a week
not probably you guys are close oh yeah
I'm in this house four or five hours
five two weeks together yeah you go I'm
going to Cabo you got to come with me
you know the wife's like that sucks you
know what I mean like oh it's just you
and him well no he goes but he'll go and
then he I come with him because you're
training him too he goes I got a train
while we're there so yeah and honest to
God he's obsessed with the [__] we were
training but we're also in Kabul so you
know kind of heals and stuff so like in
between rounds of us literally sparring
on the deck yeah you know like all right
cool you know round's over with we're
drinking like uh we're drinking yeah so
around four and five it's like all right
cool man make sure I don't [__] win
and vice versa he did like a he's really
obsessed with Andy hook spinning heel
kick right so like throw it yeah and I'm
fighting a lot of Orthodox now because
of the shoulder necklaces and stuff it
just even though it's healed up I just
for a year I had to do it this way I
really enjoy fighting that stance and
because I train people so much standing
Orthodox when I spar with him helps them
out more than Santa is a southpaw yeah
and he throws his spin heel kick I mean
like literally like I mean like miss my
testicles I was like oh man that would
have been a shitty day I'm kind of going
back to what we were talking about
outside
we want to keep the brand as this is the
future of legitimate MMA League that's
everything we don't want to be a circus
you know you don't want to be a one-off
we do the you know you got to be careful
yeah and so
yeah you made the splash with the with
the health insurance and I'm excited to
see where it goes I can't wait for your
fight Frank I'll probably be there
assume I'll be there well see Bella
kicks after the drywall who's gonna
comment should be there
he was like if the price is right if
there's one to do it it'd be that one
yeah
people people complaining like this dude
he needs to shut up about Bella man I
just hype her up way too much during the
other fights yeah I'm like yes Mike's
great I'll tell you one thing I can't
wait for it can we get a camera
backstage and belly get her hands around
you know but yeah I'd be I'd be totally
up for that man but uh yeah I'm glad we
got this done man uh I'm excited ufl's
doing some exciting stuff man I'm proud
to be around it and Harrison can't thank
you enough thank you for the support
damn thing we gotta do the companion
with uh Chris Angel that's all we got to
do
Bella's done with school in the middle
of May so if you want to know I'll bring
Bella back
yeah we'll get that fixed up she's
actually was a little bit like oh you
guys should be on the show talk about
the fight I'm not going to be there
and she knows it's like her trying to
get her away from school she's a
full-time student
classes yeah do your thing
the u.so promotes uh at the end of May
April so I mean she's focused on that
yeah yeah no when she's ready to open
door policy here for Bella man so
appreciate you guys man